>>Noah: Here, I'm able to do things
that affect how San Diegans think
about water, and I'm able to do
something where I can put my mark
on the world that I will
soon be coming into.
>>I'm Noah, 16, and I go to
the San Diego Met High School,
which is a school where
students start participating
in an internship program, beginning
in first semester of ninth grade.
Coastkeeper, their mission statement
is to have drinkable, swimmable,
and fishable waters in San Diego.
Basically, we want more fish in
our rivers, we want our rivers
to be cleaner, and we want it--
them to be less filled with trash.
>>Noah: The internship program
is a great way for students
to find new opportunities,
to do things that they might not
do during the normal school day,
meet people who they wouldn't meet,
have experiences, get training--
get trained to do things,
basically just here's how you need
to get your foot in the door.
>>Dennis: When Elliot Washor
and myself had the opportunity
to create a new school, we
really closed our eyes and said,
"If we didn't know
there was such a thing
as school, what would it be like?"
And it wouldn't be the 50 minute
classes and you ring a bell
and you run to some other place,
that's not what learning is.
>>Travis: We have low oxygen,
high bacteria then there's
really something in the water
that we need to figure out.
>>Yeah.
>>Travis: What's the worst bacteria
that we have here in San Diego?
>>Noah: Tijuana, no question.
>>Travis: No question, yeah.
>>Dennis: And so we set out
that every kid was going
to have their individual
learning plan,
what are your skills,
what are your interests?
Then we send them out
in the community
where the real world's there,
and they work two days a
week, from ninth grade on.
>>Elliot: So instead of
going from school to work,
we really go from work to school.
What are the real academics
in the real world
that are really being used, and
then use that as a motivator
to get kids more engaged in school.
>>Travis: Having Noah
working alongside me is,
I think both really valuable for
Noah, and really valuable for me.
For Noah, he gets really
an insider's look
at what it's like to have a career.
Today we went to the San Diego River
and we collected some water samples.
First thing we did is we
collected a unfiltered water sample
that we're going to bring back to the
lab and run bacteria analysis on it.
So that's how we measure if
the water is safe to swim in.
We also took a second
sample where we filtered it,
which was what we did with the pump.
That filtered water is going to
be used to measure nutrients,
and dissolved metals in the water.
>>Noah: So it's a high salinity.
>>Travis: Which is interesting
because we had a rain, recently.
>>Yeah.
>>So rain, you would expect--
>>Yeah, wash out all the salt.
>>Noah: He's shown me how to do these
things that I had no idea how to do.
He's taught me how to sample.
He's basically taught me how to use
Excel, and all the advanced formulas.
>>Travis: That's perfect.
You see how when it dips down?
>>Yeah.
>>That dip is right on the line--
>>Noah: Yeah, yeah it's perfect.
>>Travis: Noah has the same job I had
when I was 23 years old
and finishing school.
He does data entry, he does
quality control checks.
I really rely on him at this point.
You know, he's 16 years old,
and I could not do the job
that I do now without him.
>>Ready?
>>Yeah.
>>Let's go.
>>Noah: Getting off campus lets me
be able to do things and see things
that I would never be able to see,
except for like career day on campus.
>>Travis: When he graduates
high school,
he's going to have three years,
maybe four years of work experience
in a lab, and I think it's
really going to set him ahead.
When he's in college applying for
jobs, he's got that extra bump
of work experience, of
relevant work experience.
>>Noah: To have an idea of what
to expect before starting your
first job, seeing people work,
it helps you know the environment
and know where you're going.
That's what's really
great about this.